[MUSIC PLAYING]
NARRATOR: After
water, tea is the most
consumed beverage in the world.
The different types are
determined by the degree
to which the producer
lets the harvested leaves
oxidize before drying them.
Green tea, for example, is
barely fermented, whereas
black tea is greatly fermented.
Oolong falls
somewhere in between.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
In Chinese, oolong
means black dragon.
It's a semi-oxidized tea
fermented more than green tea,
yet less than black tea.
It's taste, aroma, and color,
from light yellow to dark red,
vary according to how the
tea leaves are processed.
This amber oolong
produced in Thailand
has a rich, smooth
roasted taste.
Like most teas, oolong
is made from the leaves
of a flowering plants species
called Camellia sinensis.
Harvest time is
during the plant's
peak growing season,
which in Thailand
is from May to November.
Workers handpicked what's
known as the flush.
A grouping of two young
lives and a bud, which
grows out the top of the plant.
At this time of year, the
plant produces a new flush
every seven to 15 days.
An experienced tea master
directs every phase
of the process, the
first step of which
is called solar withering.
Workers bring the
leaves into a glass
roofed building then
spread them out in the sun
for 15 to 20 minutes.
This kick starts the oxidation
fermentation process,
as the chlorophyll enzymes
inside the wilting leaves
start breaking down.
At the same time, the moisture
inside begins evaporating.
Workers keep moving the
leaves around to ensure
a thorough exposure to the sun.
Then they gather up the leaves
for step 2, indoor withering.
The leaves lie on bamboo
trays for six to eight hours,
where gently stirred every two
hours, they oxidize further.
Step 3, disruption.
The leaves go into
a rotating drum.
As they tumble, they
bruise and tear.
This breaks down the
cell structures enabling
oxygen to penetrate
deep inside, greatly
accelerating fermentation.
This also releases the
leaf juices which helps
throw out the taste of the tea.
When the tea master determines
the leaves have sufficiently
oxidized, they stop
the oxidation process
by tumbling the leaves
and a gas heated
dryer for 10 to 15 minutes.
This fourth step of the
process is called fixation,
because it fixes the oxidation
at the desired level, which
can be anywhere from 8% to
85%, depending on the variety
of oolong in production.
This is the most critical
part of the process,
because it determines the
team's taste, aroma, and color.
The next step forms the tea
leaves into tiny pellets.
First, workers shake the
leaves on a sieve to filter
out the dust-like particles.
Then they bag the
leaves in a cotton cloth
and place them first in
a kneading machine then
afterward in a rolling press.
Kneading and rolling the
back twists the leaves
inside into tiny pellets.
Forming these pellet shapes
intensifies the flavor
of the tea, and when the
tea is steeped in hot water,
releases that flavor slowly.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
They repeat the sieve,
kneading, and rolling cycle up
to 35 times until the tea master
is satisfied with the result.
Then and only then does
the final step begin.
Firing.
They transfer the tea to an
oven in which it undergoes three
drying cycles of 20 minutes
each at a temperature
of approximately 210
degrees Fahrenheit.
This dries the
damp tea, reducing
the moisture content to the
target level of less than 5%.
The firing also brings
out the fragrance.
The traditional way to brew
oolong is in a clay teapot,
using about 2 teaspoons
of tea per cup.
Ideally, the water should be
190 to 210 degrees Fahrenheit.
Steeping time is
from 3 to 10 minutes,
and you can brew the same
leaves up to five times.
[MUSIC PLAYING]